the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well actually just do a brief chapter on
Bayesian statistics and there's entire
courses on Bayesian statistics there's
an entire books on Bayesian statistics
this entire careers on Bayesian
statistics so admittedly I'm not going
to be able to do it justice and tell you
all the interesting things that are
happening in Bayesian statistics but I
think it's important as a statistician
to know what it is how it works because
it's actually a weapon of choice for
many practitioners and and because it
allows them to incorporate their
knowledge about a problem in a fairly
systematic manner
so if you look at like say the the
Bayesian statistics literature it's it's
it's huge and so here I give you you
know sort of a range of what you can
expect to see in Bayesian statistics
from your you know second edition of a
traditional book something that involves
computation some things that involve
rethinking and there's a lot of Bayesian
thinking there's a lot of things that
you know talk about sort of like
philosophy of thinking Bayesian this
book for example seems to be one of them
this book is definitely one of them this
one represents sort of a wide a broad
literature on Bayesian statistics for
applications for example in social
sciences but even in large scale machine
learning there's a lot of Bayesian
statistics happening particularly using
something called Bayesian and
parametric's or hierarchical Bayesian
modeling so we do have some experts at
MIT in the in C cell Tamra Broderick for
example is a person who does quite a bit
of interesting work on Beijing and
parametric's and if that's something you
want to know more about our duty to go
and talk to her so you know before we go
in those Oh
or advanced things we need to start with
you know what is what is the Bayesian
approach what do what do Beijing's do
and how is it different from what we've
been doing so far so to understand the
difference between Beijing's and what
we've been doing so far is we need to
first put a name on what we've been
doing so far it's called frequentist
statistics so it's usually patient
versus frequency statistics I mean by
versus I don't mean that there's
naturally in a position to them actually
often you will see the same method that
comes out of both approaches so let's
see how we did it right the first thing
we had data might we observe some data
and we assumed that this data was
generated randomly the reason we did
that is that because this would allow us
to leverage tools from probability so
let's say by nature measurements you do
a survey you get some data okay then we
made some assumptions on the data
generating process for example we assume
they were AI D that was one of the
recurring things sometimes we assume it
was Gaussian if we wanted to you say
t-test maybe we did some nonparametric
statistics we assumed it was a smooth
function or maybe linear regression
function right so those are our modeling
and this was basically a way to say well
we're not going to allow for any
distributions for the data that we have
but maybe a small set of distribution
that indexed by some small parameters
for example or at least you know remove
some of the possibilities otherwise
there's nothing that could learn and and
so for example this was associated to
some parameter of interest state theta
or beta in the regression model all
right then we had this unknown problem
and this unknown thing a known parameter
in we wanted to find it we wanted to
either estimate it or test it or maybe
you find a confidence interval for this
object all right so so far I should not
have said anything that's gonna that's
new but this last sentence is actually
what's gonna be different from the the
Bayesian part in particular this number
fix things what it's gonna be changing
alright so in the Bayesian approach we
still assume that we observe some random
data but the generating process is
slightly different it's sort of a
two-layer process and there's one
process
that generates the parameter and then
one process that given this parameter
generates data so what the first layer
does right I mean nobody really believes
that there's some random process that's
happening about you know generating what
is gonna be the true expected number of
people who turn their head to the right
when they kiss but this is actually
gonna be something that brings us some
you know easiness rest to incorporate
what we call prior belief right so we'll
see an example in a second but often you
actually have prior belief of what this
parameter should be right when we did
say these squares we looked over all of
the vectors in all of our to the P
including the ones that have
coefficients equal to you know fifty
million and so those are things that
maybe we might be able to rule out and
maybe we might be able to rule out that
a much smaller scale for example well I
mean I don't know I'm not an expert on
on you know turning your head to the
right or to the left but you know maybe
you can rule out the fact that you know
almost everybody is turning their head
in the same direction or almost
everybody's turning their head to
another direction so we want to we have
this prior belief and this prior belief
is going to play say hopefully less and
less important role as we collect more
and more data but if we have a smaller
amount of data we might want to be able
to use this information all right
rather than just shooting in the dark
and so the idea is to have this prior
belief and then we want to update this
prior belief into it what's called a
posterior belief after we've seen some
data right maybe I believe that you know
there's something that should be in some
range but maybe after I see data maybe
it's comforting me in my belief so I'm
actually having maybe a belief that's
more so belief and compasses basically
what you think and how strongly you
think about it that's what I call belief
right so for example if I have a belief
about some parameter theta
maybe my belief is telling me where
theta should be and and and how strongly
I believe in it in the sense that I have
a very narrow region where theta could
be all right and so the posterior belief
says well you see some data and maybe
you're more confident or less confident
about what you've seen
you've shifted your belief a little bit
and so that's what we're gonna try to
see and how to do this in a principled
manner so of course to understand this
better there's nothing better than an
example so let's talk about and other
stupid statistical question which is
let's try to understand P of course I'm
not going to talk about politics from
now on so there let's talk about P the
proportion of women in the population
okay and so what I could do is to
collect some data x1 xn and assume that
there Burnley with some parameter P
unknown right so P is in 0 1 ok let's
assume that those guys are ID so this is
just an indicator for each of my like
two data whether the person I randomly
sample is a woman I get a wonder if it's
a man I get a 0 okay and so now the
question is i sample these people
randomly I'd you know their their gender
and the frequentist approach was just
saying okay let's just estimate P hat
being xn bar and then we could do some
tests right so here there's a test I
want to test maybe if P is equal to 0.5
or not that sounds like a pretty
reasonable thing to test and but you
know we want to also maybe estimate P
but here this is a case where we
definitely have for our belief of what P
should be right we are pretty confident
that P is not gonna be 0.7 we actually
believe that P should be extremely close
to 1/2 okay but maybe not exactly maybe
I don't know maybe this population is
not the population in the world but
maybe this is the population of say some
college and we want to understand if
this college has half women or not right
so maybe we know it's gonna be close to
1/2 but maybe we're not quite sure and
so we're gonna want to integrate that
knowledge all right so I could integrate
it in a blunt manner by saying you know
discard the data and say that P
is equal to 1/2 but maybe that's just a
little too much so how do I do this
trade-off between you know adding the
data and combining it with this prior
knowledge in many ways in many instances
essentially what's going to happen is
this this 1/2 is going to act like one
new observation essentially so if you
have you know five observations this is
just the sixth observation which will
play a role if you have a million
observations you're gonna have a million
and one and it's not gonna play so much
of a role that's basically how it goes
that's basically how it goes but
definitely not always alright because
we'll see that if I take my prior to be
a point myself 1/2 here it's basically
as if I was recording my data so
essentially there's also your ability to
encompass how strongly you believe in
this prior and if you believe infinitely
more in the prior than you believe in
the data you collected then of course
it's not gonna act like one more
observation all right so the Bayesian
approach is a tool to one include
mathematically or prior and our prior
belief into statistical procedures right
so maybe I have this prior knowledge but
if I'm a medical doctor it's not clear
to me how I'm gonna turn this into some
principled way of building estimators
and of course the second goal is going
to be to a big this prior belief into a
posterior belief by using the data
alright so how do I do this and at some
point I sort of suggested that there's
two layers one is where you draw the
parameter at random and two once you
have the parameter conditioned on this
parameter you draw your data nobody
believes this actually is happening that
nature is just rolling dice for us and
choosing parameters that random but
what's happening is that this idea that
the parameter comes from some random
distribution actually captures very well
this idea that how you would encompass
your prior right how would you say my
belief is as follows well here's an
example about P I'm 90% sure that P is
between point four and point six
and I'm 95% sure that piece between
point three and point eight okay so
essentially I have this possible value
of P and what I know is that there's 95
there's 90 percent here between what did
I say points
four in point six and then I have point
three and point eight and I know that
I'm 95% sure that I mean here and this
if you remember this sort of looks like
the kind of pictures that I made when I
had some Gaussian right for example and
I said oh here we have ninety percent of
the observations and here we have 95
percent of the observations so in a way
if I were able to tell you all those
ranges for all possible values then I
would essentially describe a probability
distribution for P and what I'm
essentially saying is that P is gonna
have this kind of shape so of course if
I tell you only to twice this
information that there's ninety percent
I'm here and I'm here between here and
here and 95 percent I'm between here and
here then there's many ways I can
accomplish that right I could have
something that looks like this maybe
right
I could be really I mean it could be
like this I mean there's many ways that
can have this some of them are
definitely gonna be mathematically more
convenient than others and hopefully
we're gonna have things that I can
parametrize Farewell rather than because
if I tell you this is this guy then
there's basically 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
parameters right so I probably don't
want something that has 7 parameters but
maybe I can say oh it's a Gaussian and I
all I have to do is to tell you where
it's centered and what the
standardization is ok so the idea of
using this two layer thing where we
think of the parameter P as being drawn
from some distribution is really just a
way for us to capture this information
our prior belief being well you know
there's this percentage of change
that is there but the person has a
chance I'm not I'm deliberately not
using probability here it's really right
so it's really a way to get close to
this all right so that's what I say the
true parameter is not random but the
Bayesian approach does as if it was
random and then just spits out a
procedure out of this you know thought
process okay this thought experiment so
when you practice Bayesian statistics a
lot
you start getting automatisms right so
you get like you start getting some
things that you do without really
thinking about it just like when you're
a statistician the first thing you do is
you know can I think of this data as
being Gaussian for example when you're
Bayesian you're thinking about okay I
have a set of parameters right so here I
can describe my parameter as being theta
in general in some big space parameters
theta but do you know what it's what
spaces did we encounter well we
encountered the real line we encountered
the interval 0 1 for Bernoulli's and we
encountered maybe some the positive real
line for exponential distributions etc
and so what I'm gonna need to do if I
want to model some if I want to put some
prior on those spaces I'm gonna have to
have a usual set of tools for this guy
usual set of tools for this guy usual
set of two for this guy's and by usual
set of tools I mean I'm gonna have to
have a family of distributions that
support it on this so in particular this
is the speech in which my parameter that
I usually denote by P for Bernoulli lips
and so what I need is to find a
distribution on the interval 0 1 right
just like this guy the problem with the
Gaussian is that it's not on the
interval 0 1 right it's gonna spill out
in the end and it's not gonna be
something that works for me and so the
question is you know I need to think
about distributions that are probably
continuous why would I restrict myself
to discrete distributions that are
actually convenient and for Burnley one
that's actually basically the
main tool that everybody's using is the
so called beta distribution alright so
the beta distribution has two parameters
so X follows a beta with parameters say
a and B if it has a density f of X is
equal to X to the a minus 1 1 minus X to
the B minus 1 if X is in the interval 0
1 and 0 for all other X's okay so why is
that a good thing well it's a it's a
density that's on the interval 0 1 for
sure but now I have these two parameters
and the set of shapes that I can get by
tweaking those two parameters is
incredible okay I mean it's not gonna be
it's gonna be a unimodal distribution
it's still fairly nice right it's not
gonna be something that goes like this
and this because you know if you think
about this what would it mean if your
prior distribution on the interval 0 1
had this shape it would mean that maybe
you think that P is here or maybe you
think that P is here or maybe you think
that P is here which essentially mean
that you think that P can become can
come maybe from three different
phenomena and there's other models that
are called mixtures for that that
directly account for the fact that maybe
there are several phenomena that are you
know aggregated in your data set but if
you think that your data set is sort of
pure and that everything comes from the
same phenomenon you want something that
looks like maybe like this or maybe
looks like this or maybe is sort of
symmetric you want to get all this stuff
right maybe you want something that says
well you know if I'm talking about P
being the probability of the proportion
of women in the whole world you want
something that's probably really spiked
around 1/2 right
most the point mats because you know I
mean okay let's agree that 0.45 is the
actual number so you know you want
something maybe that says okay maybe I'm
wrong
but I'm sure I'm not gonna be really
that way off and so you want something
that's really pointy but if it's you
know something you've never checked
right and again I cannot make references
at this point but you know something
where you might have some uncertainty
then that should be around 1/2 maybe you
want something that's like a little more
allows you to say well I think there's
more around 1/2 but there's still some
fluctuations that are possible okay and
in particular here I talked about P
where the two parameters a and B are
actually the same I call them a when
it's called scale the other one's called
shape oh by the way sorry this is not a
density so it actually has to be
normalized right when you integrate this
guy it's going to be some function that
depends on a and B actually depends on
this function through the beta function
right which is this combination of gamma
function so that's why it's called beta
distribution but that's the definition
of the beta function when you integrate
this thing anyway so so I mean you just
have to normalize it it's just a number
that depends on the NB okay so here if
you took if you take a equal to B you
have something that essentially is
symmetric around 1/2 right because what
does it look like
well it's something so my density f of X
is gonna be what is gonna be my constant
times X times 1 minus X to the a minus 1
right and this function x times a minus
1 minus x looks like yes we've drawn it
before right that was something that
showed up as being the variance of that
was the variance of my burley so we know
it's something that you know takes its
maximum at 1/2 and now I'm just taking
your power of this guy so I'm really
just distorting this thing into some in
some fairly symmetric manner okay so the
the this distribution that we actually
take up for P right so here i assume
that pd parameter right I mean notice
this is kind of weird first of all this
is probably the first time in this
entire course that we have this has this
something has the distribution when it's
actually a lowercase letter that's
something you have to deal with because
we've been using the word case letters
for parameters and now we want them to
have a distribution so that's what's
gonna happen
all right then this is called the prior
distribution okay so really I should
write something like f of P is equal to
a constant times p1 minus p2 da minus 1
well no actually I should not because
then it's confusing
ok so let me not do this one thing in
terms of notation that I'm gonna write
I'm gonna write when I have a constant
here and I don't want to make it
explicit and we'll see in a second why
they don't need to make it explicit I'm
gonna write this as f of X it's
proportional to X 1 minus X to the minus
1 ok so that's just that's just to say
equal to some constant that does not
depend on x times this thing ok so if we
continue with our experiment now if P
right so that's the experiment where I'm
trying to I'm drawing this data x1 to xn
which is Bernoulli P if P has some
distribution it's not clear what it
means to have a burn Allah with some
random parameter so what I'm gonna do is
then I'm gonna first draw my P let's say
I get a number point 52 and then I'm
gonna draw my data conditionally on P
all right so here comes the first and
last flow chart of this class so I'm
gonna first
[Music]
all right so nature first draws P okay
so P follows say some beta a a then I
condition on P and then I draw X 1 X n
there are iid there only P everybody
understand the process of generating
this data all right so you first draw a
parameter and then you just flip this
way
those end by independent biased coins
with this particular P alright so
there's this like layered thing so now
conditionally and P right so here I have
this prior about P which was the thing
so this is just a stop process again
right it's not anything that actually
happens in practice this is my way of
thinking about how the data was
generated and from this I'm gonna try to
come up with some procedure just like if
your estimator is the average of the
data you don't have to understand
probability to say that my estimator is
the average of the data right I mean
anyone outside this room understand that
the average is a good estimator for some
you know average behavior and and they
don't need to think of the data as being
a random variable etc so same thing
basically now we will see I mean
actually we won't but in this case well
we will in this case you can see that
essentially the posterior distribution
is still a beta all right so what it
means is that I had this thing then I
observed my data and then I continued
and here I'm gonna update my prior into
some posterior distribution PI and here
this guy is actually also a beta
all right so PI now P my posterior
distribution on P is also a beta
distribution with the parameters that
are on this slide and I'll have space to
reproduce them so I start the beginning
of this flow chart as having P which is
a prior I'm gonna get some observations
and then I'm gonna update what my
posterior is okay so this posterior is
basically something that's in the big in
Bayesian statistics was beautiful is as
soon as you have the distribution it can
it's essentially capturing all the
information about the data that you want
for P and it's not just a point right
this is not just an average it's
actually an entire distribution for the
possible values of theta and it's not
the same thing as saying well you know
if theta hat is equal to xn bar in the
gaussian case i know that this is some
mean mu and then maybe it has variance
Sigma squared over n that's not what I
mean by this is my posterior
distribution right this is not what I
mean this is gonna come from this guy's
right the gaussian thing and the central
limit theorem but what I mean is this
guy and this came acutally from from the
prior distribution if I had another
prior I would not necessarily have a
beta distribution on the output so when
I have the same family of distributions
at the beginning and at the end of this
flowchart I say that beta is a conjugate
prior meaning I get I put in beta as a
prior and I get betas at but series and
that's why betas are so popular
conjugate priors are really nice because
you know that whatever you put in what
you're gonna get in the end is a beta so
all you have to think about is the
parameters you don't have to check again
what the posterior is gonna look like
what the PDF of this guy is gonna be
you'll have to think about it you just
have to check what the parameters are
and there's families of conjugate priors
Gaussian gives Gaussian for example
there's a bunch of them and this is what
drives people to into using specific
priors as rappers as opposed to other it
has nice mathematical properties nobody
believes that the P distribution is it P
is really distributed according to beta
but it's flexible enough and super
convenient mathematical alright so now
let's see from one second before we
actually go any further what I did so a
and B I didn't mention it a and B are
both and here B and B are positive
numbers okay they can be anything
positive so here what I did is that I
updated a into a plus the sum of my data
and B into B plus n minus the sum of my
data so that's essentially a becomes a
plus the number of ones and B becomes B
well that's only when a and I have a na
right so the first parameters become
itself plus the number of ones and the
second one becomes itself plus the
number of zeros right and so just as a
sanity check what does this mean if a
goes to zero what is the beta when a
goes to zero we can actually read this
from here right right so we had a sorry
actually let's take a goes to no
actually sorry let's just do this
okay let's not do this now I'll do it
when we talk about not informative prior
because it's a it's a little too messy
yeah okay so how do we do this how did I
get this posterior distribution given
the prior how do I update this well this
is called Bayesian statistics and you've
heard this word Bayes before and the way
you've heard it is in the base formula
right what was the base formula the base
formula was telling you that the
probability of a given B was equal to
something that depended on the
probability of B given a right that's
what it was and III mean you can
actually either remember the formula you
can remember the definition and this is
what P of a and B divided by P of B so
this is P of B given a times P of a
divided by P of B right that's what base
formula is telling you agree so now what
I want is to have something that's
telling me how this is how this is gonna
work okay
so what is gonna play the role of those
events a and B well one is gonna be what
is the this so this is gonna be the
distribution of my parameter theta given
that I see the data and this is gonna
tell me what is the distribution of the
data given that I know what my parameter
of theta is but that part if this is
data and this is the parameter of theta
this is what we have been all along
we've been doing all along the
distribution of the data given the
parameter here was an iid Bernoulli P I
know that I know exactly what their
joint probability mass function is then
that was what so we said that let this
is going to be my data and this is gonna
be my parameter okay so that means that
this is the probability of my data given
the parameter this is a probability
given the product this is the
probability of the parameter what is
this what did we call this this is the
prior it's just
distribution of my parameter now what is
this well this is just a distribution of
the data itself alright so this is
essentially the distribution of this if
this was indeed a if I mean not
conditioned on P right so if I don't
condition on P this data is gonna be a
bunch of iid bernly with some parameter
but the parameter is random right so for
different realization of this data set
I'm gonna get different parameters for
the Bernoulli and so that leads to some
sort of you know convolution I mean it's
not really convolution in this case but
it's like some sort of composition of
distributions right to have the
distribution it comes the randomness
that comes from here and then the
randomness that come from realizing the
Bernoulli right so that's just a
marginal distribution it's actually
might be painful to understand what this
is right I mean in a way it's sort of a
mixture and it's not super nice but
we'll see that this actually won't
matter for us this is gonna be some
number it's gonna be there but it won't
matter for us what it is because it
actually does not depend on the
parameter and that's all that matters to
us okay
so let's put some names on those things
right I mean this was very informal so
let's put some actual names on what we
want to call what we call prior so what
is the formal definition of a prior what
is the form of this definition of a
posterior and what are the rules to
update it okay so I'm gonna have my data
which is gonna be x1 xn and so let's say
they are iid but they don't actually
have two and so I'm gonna have given
theta
and when I say given it's either given
like I did in the first part of this
class at this course you know previous
chapters or conditionally on right so
that's assuring if you're thinking like
a Bayesian that what I really mean is
conditionally on this random parameter
okay so it's like as if it was a fixed
number
then I'm gonna have they're gonna have
the distribution x1 xn is gonna have
some distribution let's say let's assume
for now it's a PDF PN of X 1 xn okay and
I'm gonna write theta like this so for
example what is this well that's so
that's it this is a PDF it could be a
PMF everything I say I'm gonna think of
them them as being PDFs I'm going to
combine PDFs with PDF but I could
combine PDF at pmf's PMF with PDFs or
PMF with pms okay so everywhere you see
a deed could be an M alright so now I
have those things so what does that mean
so here's some example X 1 xn are iid
and theta 1 right so now I know exactly
what the joint PDF of this thing is so
it means that P n of X 1 X n given theta
is equal to what well it's like 1 over
Sigma root sorry 1 or 2 root 2 pi to the
power n e to the minus sum from I equal
1 to N of X I minus theta squared
divided by 2 right so that's just the
Joint Distribution of n iid and theta 1
random variables ok so that's my pian
given theta now this is what we denoted
by sort of like f sub theta before right
we had this subscript before but now we
just put a bar in there because we want
to remember that this is actually
conditioned on theta right but this is
just notation you should just think of
this as being just the usual thing that
you get from some statistical model all
right so now that's going to be PN and
here I'm going to assume that theta is
why do I put PI here
okay so theta has prior distribution pi
okay so for example so think of it as
either PDF or PMF again so for example
PI of theta was what well it was my it
was some constant times theta to the a
minus 1 1 minus theta to the a minus 1
right so it has some prior distribution
and that's another PMS so now I'm given
the distribution of my X's given theta
I'm given the distribution of my theta
so I'm given this guy right
that's this guy I'm given that guy which
is my pi
right so that's my PN of X 1 xn given
theta
that's my pi of theta and then I have
here just this is what well this is just
the integral of PN X 1 X n times pi of
theta D theta right over all possible
sets of theta that's just when I
integrate out my theta or I compute say
the marginal distribution I get this by
integrating right that's just basic
probability conditional probabilities
all right then if I had the PMF I would
just sum over the values of Thetas okay
so now what I want is to find what's
called so that's the prior distribution
that's the posterior and I want to find
the posterior distribution so it's cool
it's PI of theta given x1 xn and so if I
use Bayes rule I know that this is PN of
X 1 xn given theta times PI of theta and
then divided by the distribution of
those guys which I will write as
integral over theta of PN X 1 xn given
theta times Phi of theta and D theta
everybody's with me still so if you're
not comfortable with this isn't means
that you probably need to go read your
couple pages on conditional densities
and conditional pmfs from your
probability class there's really not
much there it's just a matter of being
able to define those quantities f
density of X given Y this is just what's
called a conditional density you need to
understand what this object is and how
it relates to the Joint Distribution of
X and y or maybe the distribution of X
for the distribution of Y but it's the
same rules I mean one way to actually
remember this is this is exactly the
same rules as this when you see a bar
it's the same thing as the probability
of this end this guy so for densities
it's just a comma divided by the by the
second guy the probability of the second
guy that's it all right so if you
remember this you can just do some
pattern matching and see what I just
wrote here okay okay so now I can
compute every single one of these guys
this
it's something I get from my modeling so
I did not write this it's not written in
in the slides but you know I give a name
to this guy that was my prior
distribution and that was my posterior
distribution in the Quran chapter 3
maybe what did we call this guy well the
one that does not have a name and that's
in the Box this guy how did we call it
it is to join distribution of the excise
and we give you the name
it's the likelihood right this is
exactly the likelihood this with the
likelihood of theta and this is
something that's very important to
remember and that really reminds you
that these things are really not that
different maximum likelihood estimation
Bayesian estimation because your
posterior is really just your likelihood
times something that's just putting some
weights on the Thetas depending on where
you think theta should be all right so
if I had say maximum likelihood
estimator and my likelihood until I look
like this but my prior and theta looked
like this I said oh I really want data
sort of like this so what's gonna happen
is that my I'm gonna turn this into some
posterior that looks like this okay so
I'm just really weighting this this
posterior this is a constant that does
not depend on theta right I agreed I
integrated over theta so theta is going
so forget about this guy I have
basically that the posterior
distribution of to scaling because it
has to be a probability density and not
just anything any function that's
positive is the product of this guy it's
a weighted version of my likelihood
that's all it is
I'm just waiting the
hood using my prior belief in theta and
so given this guy a natural estimator if
you follow the maximum likelihood
principle would be the maximum of this
posterior agreed that would basically be
doing exactly what maximum likelihood
estimation is telling you so it turns
out that you can
it's called maximum a-posteriori and I
won't talk much about this or map so
that's maximum a-posteriori so it's just
the theta hat is the org max of pi theta
given X 1 xn it sounds like it's okay I
give you a density and you say okay I
have a density for all values of my
parameters you're asking me to summarize
it into one number I'm just gonna take
the most likely number of those guys but
you could summarize it otherwise you
could take the average right you could
take the median you could take a bunch
of numbers and the beauty of Bayesian
statistics is that you don't have to
take any number in particular you have
an entire posterior distribution this is
not only telling you where theta is but
it's actually telling you the difference
if you actually give as a something it
gives you the posterior right so now
let's say the theta is a P between 0 & 1
if my posterior distribution looks like
this or if my posterior distribution
looked like this then those two guys
have one the same mode right this is the
same value and they're symmetric so they
also have the same mean so these two
posterior distributions give me the same
summary into one number however clearly
one is much more confident than the
other one so I might as well just spit
that as a solution okay
some people can you can do even better
people actually do things such as
drawing a random number from this
distribution so this is my number well
that's kind of adventurous but you can
imagine you could do this right all
right
so this is what works that's what we
went through so here is you notice I I
don't care so much about this part here
right because it does not depend on
theta so it's not it's I know that given
the product of those two things this
thing is only the constant that I need
to device that when I integrate this
thing over theta it integrates to 1
because this has to be a probability
density on theta so I can write this and
just forget about that part and that's
what's really on the on the top of this
line okay just this notation this sort
of like weird alpha or I don't know
infinity sign crop to the right whatever
you want to call this this thing is
actually just really emphasizing the
fact that I don't care I write it
because I mean yeah I write it because I
can but and you know what it is but you
don't actually have to well okay in some
instances you have to compute the
integral in some instances you don't
have to compute the integral and a lot
of Bayesian computation is about saying
okay it's actually really hard to
compute this integral so I'd rather not
doing it so let me try to find some
methods that allow me to sample from the
posterior distribution without having to
compute this and that's what's called
Monte Carlo Markov chains or MCMC and
that's exactly what they're doing
they're just using only ratios of things
like that for different datas and which
means that if you take ratios the
normalizing constant is going and you
don't need to find this integral ok so
we won't go into those details at all
that would be the purpose of an entire
course on Bayesian inference actually
even Bayesian computations would be an
entire course on its own and there's
some very interesting things that are
going on there the interface of stats
and computation all right so let's go
back to our example and see if we can
actually compute any of those things
because it's very nice to give you some
data some formulas but you know let's
see if we can actually do it all right
that in particular can I actually
recover this claim that the posterior
associated to a burn to a beta prior
with Burnley
likelihood is actually giving me a beta
again all right so what was my prior
well it was beta so P was following a
beta a a which means that P the density
so that was PI of theta well I'm gonna
write it as Phi of Phi of P was
proportional to P to the a minus 1 times
1 minus P to the a minus 1 right so
that's the first ingredient I need to
compute my posterior I really need only
two if I want it about up to constant
the second one was PA
well we've computed that many times and
we had even a nice compact way of
writing it which was that PN of X 1 xn
given a parameter P right so the density
the joint density of my data given P
that's my likelihood the likelihood of P
was what well it was P to the some of
the excise 1 minus P to the N minus some
of the excise anybody wants me to parse
this more or do you remember seeing that
from maximum likelihood estimation yeah
that's what conditioning does
okay so deep I of T is a measure
theoretic notation which I use without
thinking and I should not because I can
see yeah that's you D PI of T is just a
natural way to say that I integrate
against whatever and given for the the
prior of theta in particular if theta is
just the mix of a PDF and a point mass
right maybe I say that my P takes value
0.5 with probability 0.5 and then is
uniform on the interval with probability
0.5 okay so for this I neither have a
PDF nor a PMF but I can still talk about
integrating with respect to this right
it's going to look like if I take a
function f of T D PI of T is going to be
one-half of F 1/2 right that's the point
mass with probability one half at one
half plus one half of the integral
between 0 and 1 of F of T DT alright so
this is just a notation which is
actually internally enough is
interchangeable with PI of DT but if you
have a density it's really just the
density PI of T DT if I is really a
density but that's when it's when PI is
a measure in other density but so
everybody else forget about this I mean
this is not something you should really
worry about at this point this is more
graduate-level probability classes but
yet school major theory and that's when
you think of PI as being a measure in an
abstract fashion you'll have to worry
whether it's a density or not whether it
has a density even ok
so everybody's okay with this all right
so now I need to compute my posterior
and as I said my posterior is really
just a product of the likelihood
weighted by the prior right so hopefully
by at this stage of your education you
can multiply two functions alright so
what's happening is if I multiply this
guy with this guy well P gets this guy
to the power this guy plus this guy and
then 1 minus P gets the power n minus
some of Excise so this is always from I
equal 1 to N and then plus a minus 1 as
well okay and this is sorry this is up
to constant because I still need to
solve this and I could try to do it but
I really don't have to because I know
that if my density has this form then
it's a beta distribution and then I can
just go in Wikipedia and see what should
be the normalization factor but I know
it's going to be a beta distribution
it's actually the beta with parameter so
this is really my beta with parameter
sum of X I I equal 1 to N plus a minus 1
and then the second parameter is n minus
sum of the x i's plus a minus 1 ok sorry
I just wrote what was here Oh what
happened to my 1 oh no sorry sorry sorry
beta has the power minus 1 right so
that's that's the parameter of the beta
and this is the parameter of the beta
right so beta well I don't think it's
anywhere yeah beta is over there right
so I just replaced a by what I see is
just
this guy plus this guy in this guy push
this guy everybody's comfortable with
this competition all right so we just
agreed that beta priors for Burnley
observations are certainly convenient
right and because they're just
conjugated and we know that's what's
gonna come out in the end that's gonna
be a beta as well so I mean you know I
just claimed it was convenient
it was certainly convenient to compute
this right I mean there was some
certainly some compatibility when I had
to multiply this function by that
function and you can imagine that things
could go much more wrong than just
having P to some power and Peterson
power one minus P to some power when I
just be to some other power things were
nice now this is nice but they can also
question the following things
why beta for one I mean the beta tells
me something but you know that's
convenient but then how do I pick a I
know that a should definitely capture
the fact that I want where I want to
have my P most likely located but it
also actually it also captures the
variance of my beta and so choosing
different A's is gonna have different
functions if I have a and B if I started
with the beta with parameter if here I
started with a B here I would just pick
up the be here agreed and that would
just be a symmetric but they're gonna
capture mean and variance of this thing
and so how do I pick those guys right I
mean if I'm a doctor and I'm you're
asking me what do you think the chances
of this drug working and this kind of
patients is and I have to say to speed
up the parameters of a beta for you it
might be a bit of a complicated thing to
do so how do you do this especially for
problems so by now people have actually
you know found mastered the art of
coming up with you know what how to
formulate those numbers but in new
problems that come up how do you do this
what do you happens if you want to use
Bayesian methods but you actually do not
know what you expect to see maybe this
is the first time you I mean to be fair
before we started this class I hope all
of you had no idea whether people 10th
to bend their head to the right or to
the left before kissing because if you
did well you have too much time on your
hand and I should double your homework
and so in this case you have to sort of
maybe you still want to use the Bayesian
machinery maybe you just want to do
something nice it's nice right I mean it
worked out pretty well and so what if
you want to do well you actually want to
use some priors that have no carry no
information that basically do not prefer
any theta to another theta now you could
read this slide or you could look at
this formula we just said that this pi
here was just here to weigh some
theaters more than others depending on
our prior belief if our prior belief
does not want to put any preference
towards some Thetas than to others what
do I do
yeah I remove it and the way to remove
something with x is just replace it by
one that's really what we're doing right
so if this was a constant and not
depending on theta then that would mean
that we're not preferring any theta and
we're looking sort of the likely I'd add
the likelihood but not as a function
that we're trying to maximize but as a
function that we normalize in such a way
that it's actually a distribution so if
I have Pi which is not here this is
really just taking the lag field which
is a positive function may not integrate
to one so I normalize it so that it
integrates to 1 and then I just say well
this is my posterior distribution now I
could just maximize this thing and spit
out my maximum likelihood estimator but
now I can also integrate and find what
the expectation of this guy is I can
find what the median if this guy is I
can sample data from this guy I can
build you know understand what the
variance of this guy is which is
something we did not do when we just did
maximum likelihood estimation because
given a function all we cared about was
the maximum of the arc max of this
function okay so if you knew this this
that priors are called uninformative all
right so this is just replacing this
number by one and if I have a or by a
constant right because it still has to
be a density and so if I have something
which is
if I have a ballot said I'm just looking
for the uniform distribution on this
ballot set the one that puts constant 1
over the size of this thing but if I
have an invalid set what is what is the
density that takes a constant value on
the entire real line for example what is
this density doesn't exist right I mean
it just doesn't exist I mean you know
you the way you can think of it is a
Gaussian with the variance going to
infinity maybe or something like this
but you can think of it in many ways you
can think of the limit of the uniform
between minus T and T with T going to
infinity but this thing is actually zero
right I mean there's there's nothing
there and so when you're you can
actually still talk about this right you
could always talk about this thing where
you think of this guy as being a
constant remove this thing from this
equation and just say well my posterior
is just the likelihood divided by the
integral of the likelihood over theta
and if theta is the entire real line so
be it as long as this integral converges
you can still talk about this stuff and
so this is what's called an improper
prior right that improper prior is just
a down- function the final data but it
does not have to integrate neither to
one nor to anything okay it does not
have to right if I integrate the
function equal to one on the entire real
line what do I get infinity right I mean
it's not it's not a proper integral and
so it's not a proper prior it's called
an improper prior and those improper
priors are usually what you see when you
start to want non informative priors on
infinite sets Thetas I mean that's just
the nature of it it's just you should
think of it as being the uniform prior
and some infinite the uniform
distribution and some infinite set if
that thing were to exist okay so let's
see some examples about non informative
priors right so if I'm on the uniform if
I'm on the inter
zero-one this is a finite set so I can
talk about the uniform prior and the
interval 0 1 for prouder PE of a
Bernoulli okay and so so if I want to if
I want to talk about this then it means
that my prior is P follows some uniform
on the interval 0 1 ok so that means
that the density is well f of X is 1
if X is in 0 1 and 0 otherwise there's
actually not even a normalization this
thing integrates to 1 and so now if I
look at my likelihood it's still the
same thing so my posterior becomes theta
X 1 X n so that's my posterior I don't
write the likelihood again because we
still have it here well we don't have it
there anymore is it here how did I just
do it
yeah the likelihood is given here all
right so copy-paste over there and so
the posterior is just this thing times 1
so you will see it in a second so it's P
times the sum to the power some of the
excise 1 minus P to the power n minus
some of the excise and then it's like
multiplied by 1 and then divided by this
integral between 0 and 1 of P some of
the excise one minus P n minus some of
the excise D P which does not depend on
P and I really don't care what this
thing actually is okay so now sorry
that's
prior posterior of C of P and now I can
see well what is this well it's actually
just the beta
with parameters this guy plus one and
this guy plus one so I didn't tell you
what the expectation of a beta was right
we don't know what the expectation of a
beta is agreed I mean if I wanted to
find say the expectation of this thing
that would be some good estimator we
know that the maximum of this guy what
is the maximum of this thing oh it's
just this thing right I mean it's the
average of the excise right that's just
the maximum likelihood estimator for
burning we know it's the average do you
think if I take the expectation of this
thing I'm going to get the average
so actually I'm not gonna get the
average I'm gonna get this guy plus this
guy divided by n plus one so I'm gonna
do as if I had sorry okay let me not say
it like that let's look at what this
thing is doing it's looking at the
number of zeros it's in the number of
ones and it's adding one and this guy is
looking at the number of zeros and it's
adding one okay why is it adding this
one what's going on here
well what would happen if I had so this
actually is going to matter mostly when
the number of ones is actually zero or
the number of zeros is zero because what
it does is just pushes the zero from non
zero and why is that something that this
vision method actually does for you
automatically is because when we put
this non-affirmative prior on P which
was uniform on the interval 0 1 in
particular we know that the probability
that P is equal to 0 is 0 and the
probability P is equal to 1 is 0 and so
the problem is that essentially if I did
not add this one with some positive
probability it would be allowed to spit
out something that actually had had P
hat which was equal to 0 in the case if
by chance let's say I have n is equal to
3 and I get only 0 0 0 right that could
happen with probability 1 over P cubed 1
over 1 minus P Q sorry 1 minus P cube
then this thing is just gonna not that's
not something that I want and I'm
actually using my prior so my prayer is
not infirmities but somehow it captures
the fact that I don't want to believe
that P is gonna be either equal to 0 1
okay and so that's sort of taken care of
here okay so let's move away a little
bit from the birnley example shall we I
mean we think we've seen enough of it
and so let's talk about the Gaussian
model right let's say I want to do
Gaussian inference in the in the I want
to do inference in a Gaussian model
using Bayesian methods okay so I'm gonna
actually look at so
okay so what I want is that X I X 1 X n
or say and 0 1 idea
sorry theta 1
iid conditionally on theta ok so that
means that PN of X 1 X n given theta is
equal to well exactly what I wrote
before so 1 square root 2 pi to the N
exponential minus 1/2 sum of X I minus
theta squared ok so that's just the
Joint Distribution of my end Gaussian
with mean theta and now the question is
what is the posterior distribution okay
well here I said let's use the
uninformative prior which is an improper
prior right it puts weight 1 on every
one that's the so-called uniform on the
entire real line so that's certainly not
a density but I can still just use this
right so all I need to do is to is to
get this divided by normalizing this
thing right so that's what I need to do
but if I look at this right so
essentially I want to understand so this
is proportional to the exponential minus
1/2 sum from I equal 1 to N of X I minus
theta squared and now I want to see this
thing as a density not on the excise but
on theta right what I want is a density
on theta so it looks like I have chances
of getting something that looks like a
Gaussian but if I really need to have a
Gaussian I would need to see minus 1/2
and then I would need to see theta minus
something here ok not just the sum of
something minus Thetas so I need to work
a little bit more so I can see what this
to expand the square here so this thing
here is going to be equal to exponential
minus 1/2 sum from 1 to N of X I squared
minus
two x plus theta squared okay
[Applause]
okay and so now basically what I'm gonna
do is everything remember is up to this
little sign right so every time I see a
term that does not depend on theta I can
just push it in there and just make it
disappear agreed okay
this term here exponential minus 1/2 sum
of X I squared does it depend on theta
no so I'm just pushing it here this guy
yes and the other one yes so this is
proportional to exponential X I I'm
sorry some of the X I and then I'm gonna
pull out my theta the minus 1/2 cancel
with the minus 2 and then I have minus
1/2 sum from I can 1 to N of theta
squared right agreed
so now what this thing looks like well
this looks very much like some theta
minus something squared this thing here
is really just n over 2 times theta so
sorry times theta squared so now what I
need to do is to write this of the form
theta minus something let's call it mu
squared
maybe divided by Sigma divided by 2
Sigma squared right
I want to turn this into that maybe up
to terms that do not depend on theta
that's what I'm gonna try to do so
that's called completing the square and
that's some exercise you do you've done
it probably already in the homework and
that's something you do a lot when you
do Bayesian statistics in particular so
let's do this well what is gonna be the
leading term where theta squared is
going to be multiplied by this thing so
I'm gonna pull out my n over 2 and then
I'm gonna write this as theta squared
minus and Y sorry minus theta over 2 and
then I'm gonna write theta square of
theta minus something squared and this
something is going to
one half of what I see in the cross
product right well I need to actually
pull this thing out so okay let me write
it like that first so that's theta
squared and then I'm gonna write it as
minus two times one over n sum from I
equal one to n of excise times theta
right that's exactly just a rewriting of
what we had before
and that should look much more familiar
x squared minus eight sorry a squared
minus two blob a and then I miss
something
so this thing I'm gonna be able to
rewrite as theta minus xn bar squared
but then I need to remove the square of
xn bar because it's not here okay so I
just complete the square and then I
actually really don't care what this
thing actually was because it's gonna go
again in the little alpha sign over
there so this thing eventually is going
to be proportional to exponential of
minus n over 2 times theta minus xn bar
squared and so we know that if this is a
density that's proportional to this guy
it has to be some N
with mean xn bar and variance well this
is supposed to be 1 over Sigma squared
this guy over here this n so that's
really just 1 over n ok so the posterior
distribution is a Gaussian centered at
my the average of my observations and
with variance 1 over n ok everybody's
with me so just why I'm saying this I
mean this is what the output of some
computation but it sort of makes sense
right it's really telling me that the
more observations I have the more
concentrated this posterior is
concentrated around what well around
this xn bar so that looks like something
we've sort of seen before but it does
not have the same meaning somehow this
is really just the posterior
distribution and it's not really I mean
it sort of says it's sort of a sanity
check that I have this 1 over N when I
have xn bar but it's not the same thing
as saying that the variance of xn bar
was 1 over n like we had before ok so as
an exercise well you probably will have
it but I would recommend if you don't
get it
just try pi of theta to be equal to some
n mu 1 ok so you start so here the prior
that we use was completely non
informative what happens if i take my
prior to be some Gaussian which is
centered at new and it has the same
variance as the other guys ok so what's
gonna happen here is that we're gonna
put a weight and everything that's away
from you is gonna actually get less
weight right and I want to know how I'm
gonna be updating this prior into a
posterior so that's right so everybody
sees what I'm saying here so PI of theta
is just so that means that PI of theta
has the density proportional to X
financial minus 1/2 theta minus mu
squared right so I need to multiply my
my posterior with this and then see what
it's like actually gonna be a Gaussian
this is also a conjugate prior it's
gonna spit out another Gaussian you're
gonna have to complete a square again
and just check what it's actually giving
you and so spoiler alert it's gonna look
like you get an extra observation which
is actually equal to MU okay so it's
gonna it's gonna be the average of n
plus 1 observations the first n ones
being x1 to xn in the last one being mu
and it sort of makes sense okay so
that's actually a fairly simple exercise
but before rather than going into more
computation this is something you can
definitely do in your in the comfort of
your room I want to talk about other
types of priors right so the first thing
I said is okay all right there's this
being a prior that I just pull out of my
hat and that was just convenient then
there was this not informative prior and
was convenient great was not informative
so if you don't know anything else maybe
that's what you want to do the question
is are there any other priors that are
sort of principled and generic in the
sense that they in uninformative prior
was generic right I mean it was equal to
one that's as generic as it gets and so
is there anything that's generic as well
well there's this priors that are called
Jeffress priors and jeffers prior is a
prior which is proportional to square
root of the determinant of the Fisher
information of theta okay and so this is
actually kind of a weird thing to do
right it says compute your look at your
model right your model is gonna have a
Fisher information let's say it exists
and because you know we know it does not
always exist for example in the
multinomial model we didn't have a
Fisher information and so the
determinant of a matrix is somehow
measuring the size of a matrix right and
if you don't trust me just think about
the matrix being of size one by one then
the determinant is just the number that
you have there and so this is really
something that looks like the Fisher
information
I mean it's just basically the amount of
information is proportional to the
amount of information that you have at a
certain point okay and so what my prior
is saying it's saying well I want to put
more weights on those Thetas that are
gonna just like extract more information
from the data okay so you can actually
compute those things right so in the
first example Jefferies Pryor is
something that looks like this right I
mean in one dimension Fisher information
is essentially one over the variance
right so that's just 1 over the square
root of the variance because I have the
square root and when I have the uniform
sorry the Jeffress prior when i have the
gaussian case right so yeah this is the
identity matrix that I would have in the
gaussian case so the determinant of the
identity is 1 so square root of 1 is 1
and so I would basically get 1 that
gives me my improper prior that I might
uninformative prior that I had okay so
the uninformative prior 1 is fine I mean
you know clearly all the Thetas carry
the same information in the Gaussian
model right I mean whether I translate
it here or here it's pretty clear not
none of them is actually better than the
other but clearly for the Burnham Lee
case the peas that are closer the piece
that are closer to the boundary right
carry more information right so I sort
of like those guys because they're just
like carry more information so what I do
is that I take this function so P 1
minus P remember is something that looks
like this on the interval 0 1 0 and 1 so
this guy 1 over square root of P 1 minus
P something that looks like this
agreed and so what it's doing is sort of
like wants to push towards the piece
that actually carry more information I
mean whether you want to bias your data
that way or not to something you need to
think about right I mean when you put a
prior on your data on your parameter
you're sort of like biasing towards this
idea your data and maybe you know that's
maybe not such a good idea when you have
when you're you're you have some P
that's actually close to 1/2 for example
you're actually saying no I don't want
to see a PITA
goes to 1/2 just make a decision one way
or another but just make a decision so
it's sort of forcing you to do that okay
and so Geoffrey's prior so I'm running
out of time so I don't want to go into
too much details but we'll probably stop
here actually so so Geoffrey's prior
okay sorry what happened here yeah so
Geoffrey's priors have this very nice
property is that they actually do not
care about the parameterization of your
space ok so if you actually have P and
you suddenly decide that P is not the
right parameter for Bo burn Allah but
it's P squared okay you could decide to
parameterize this by P squared maybe
your doctor is actually much more able
to formulate some prior assumption on P
squared rather than P you never know and
so what happens is that Jeffrey's priors
are invariant under this and the reason
is because well the information carried
by P is the same as the information
carried by P squared somehow right I
mean those are essentially the same
I mean well yeah they're essentially the
same thing and so so I mean you need to
have a one-to-one map right were you
basically for each parameter before you
have another parameter so let's call ETA
the new parameters then the PDF of so
the PDF of the new prior index by ETA
this time is actually also Jeffrey's
prior but this time the new Fisher
information is not the Fisher
information with respect to theta but it
says in the Fisher information this
associated to the statistical model
indexed by ETA so essentially when you
change Geoffrey's prior you still when
you change the parameter ization of your
model you still get Geoffrey's prior for
the new parameterization which is in a
way a desirable property all right so
that's so Jeffrey's priors just like
none uninformative priors or priors you
want to use when you don't when you want
a systematic way without really thinking
about what to pick for your mouth
so well okay I'll finish this next time
and we'll talk about Bayesian confidence
regions will talk about Bayesian
estimation once I have a purpose here
what do I get and basically the only
message is going to be that well you
might want to integrate against the
posterior find the posterior the
expectation of your posterior
distribution that's a good point
estimator for theta and then we'll just
do well just do a couple of computation
all right so